>> Laura: THIS JUST IN.
JERRY NADLER NOW LEVELLING
THREATS AND PLACING A TIMELINE
ON ROBERT MUELLER.
THE MAN HE AND THE DEMOCRATS
THOUGHT WOULD BRING PRESIDENT
TRUMP DOWN.
SAYING A SUBPOENA IS COMING
BEFORE THE END OF THE SUMMER.
JOINING ME NOW, SOL WISENBERG
AND ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
ALAN, THE DEMOCRATS ARE PUSHING
FOR MUELLER'S TESTIMONY.
BUT IS IT POSSIBLE THAT THE
GOP'S CASE COULD BE STRENGTHENED
BY HIS APPEARANCE?
>> IT'S POSSIBLE.
BUT THERE'S NO USE TO HAVING HIM
TESTIFY.
THE MUELLER REPORT NEVER SHOULD
HAVE BEEN WRITTEN.
THERE'S NO ROOM UNDER OUR
CONSTITUTION FOR SPECIAL
COUNSEL, SPECIAL PROSECUTORS,
REPORTS.
PROSECUTORS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
SAY ONE THING.
WE HAVE CONCLUDED THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE SUFFICIENT TO CHARGE
THE PRESIDENT WITH RUSSIAN
COLLUSION OR OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, PERIOD.
I'M TAKING NO QUESTIONS, MAKE
NOTHING PUBLIC REPORT.
I'M GIVING MY FINDINGS TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
NO PROSECUTOR SHOULD GO BEYOND
THAT.
WE AGREED WITH THAT WHEN COMEY
WENT BEYOND THAT WITH HILLARY
CLINTON.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE CRITICISM
OF COMEY FOR SAYING THAT HILLARY
CLINTON ENGAGED IN EXTREME
CARELESSNESS.
EVERYBODY CRITICIZED THAT.
AND THEN WE WANT TO KNOW WHY
MUELLER DIDN'T CHARGE THE
PRESIDENT.
IT'S THE SAME THING.
THE WHOLE ENTERPRISE OF SPECIAL
COUNSEL, SPECIAL PROSECUTORS IS
INCONSISTENT WITH THE
CONSTITUTION.
I HOPE WE'VE SEEN THE LAST OF
IT.
>> Laura: NOW, SOL, YOU WERE
WATCHING JOHN DEAN'S SHOW
YESTERDAY WHERE HE TESTIFIED ON
THE HILL.
PURPORTING TO DRAW A CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE WATERGATE ROAD MAP
TO IMPEACHMENT AND WHAT
MUELLER'S REPORT REPRESENTS.
YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THEY'RE
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT.
THE GRAND JURY WAS VERY CAREFUL
NOT TO MAKE ANY CONCLUSIONS.
THEY SAID HERE'S -- ON MARCH 17,
1973, PRESIDENT NIXON HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THESE TWO
PEOPLE.
THEN THEY LISTED THE TAPE
RECORDINGS AND THE GRAND JURY
TESTIMONY THAT THE HOUSE COULD
LOOK AT.
TOTALLY DIFFERENT THAN THE
MUELLER REPORT, WHICH MADE A
NUMBER OF LEGAL AND FACTUAL
CONCLUSIONS.
NUMBER 1.
NUMBER 2, MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR
THE PEOPLE THAT STILL BELIEVE
THAT FIRING JAMES COMEY COULD
EVER BE CRIMINAL OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, THE WATERGATE ROAD MAP
WHICH WAS ALL ABOUT OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE, THAT'S WHAT THE
GRAND JURY INDICTED PEOPLE FOR,
NEVER IN ANY WAY MENTIONS THE
FIRING OF ARCHIE COX IN
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
I LOOKED AT ABOUT EVERY BOOK ON
WATERGATE.
I DON'T BELIEVE JAWORSKI'S
PEOPLE MENTIONED IT.
>> AND NOBODY TALKED ABOUT IT
YESTERDAY AND THAT'S GEORGE H.W.
BUSH.
PARDONING CASPER WINEBERGER,
PARDONING THE FIVE PEOPLE ON THE
EVE OF THEIR TRIAL.
THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR SAID THAT
WAS DESIGNED TO STOP THE
INVESTIGATION AND IT DID STOP
THE INVESTIGATION.
NOBODY EVER SUGGESTED
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE AGAINST
PRESIDENT BUSH.
>> Laura: LET'S GET BACK TO
CURRENT DAY.
SHEILA JACKSON LEE WAS SPEAKING
TODAY ON THE CIVIL CONTEMPT
CITATIONS THAT ARE BEING FLOATED
AROUND FOR BARR, ET CETERA.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WE WILL SEE WHAT WE'LL DO
NEXT IF THE COMPLIANCE
CONTINUES, THEN WE'LL TAKE THE
NEGLIGENCE ACTION OFF THE TABLE.
EVERYTHING REMAINS ON THE TABLE
UNTIL WE KNOW THEY HAVE FULLY
COMPLIED WITH THE INFORMATION WE
NEED.
>> Laura: ALAN, IS THERE ANY
THERE THERE.
>> THERE'S NO THERE THERE.
>> Laura: THE CAT AND MOUSE GAME
WITH THE WHITE HOUSE OFFICE.
>> THERE'S NO THERE THERE.
THERE'S NO LEGAL OBLIGATION TO
PROVIDE THE PUBLIC OR CONGRESS
WITH ANY OF THE INFORMATION.
CERTAINLY NOT INFORMATION THAT
IS PROTECTED BY GRAND JURY
SECRECY THAT INVOLVES ONGOING
INVESTIGATIONS.
IT VIOLATES THE SEPARATION OF
POWERS FOR CONGRESS TO TRY TO
COMPEL DISCLOSURE INFORMATION
THAT THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH HAS
THE RIGHT TO MAINTAIN SECRECY
OVER.
NOT FOREVER.
BUT WHILE THERE'S PENDING
INVESTIGATIONS AND UNTIL A JUDGE
CLEARS THE GRAND JURY.
WHAT THEY'RE ASKING BARR TO DO
IS VIOLATE THE LAW.
NO COURT WILL COMPEL AN ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO VIOLATE THE LAW.
>> Laura: BARR, I SHOULD HAVE
REFERRED TO DOJ, NOT WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL.
I WAS REFERENCE
I WAS REFERENING McGAHN.
BUT THAT'S THE CASE, SOL NO,
COMPLIANCE HAS TAKEN CASE.
SEEMS LIKE THEY WENT OVERBOARD.
THEY GAVE UP TOO MUCH
INFORMATION IN THIS PROCESS.
SOL, CLOSE IT OUT.
>> NOT ONLY THAT, BUT THINK OF
THE CASE OF DAVID SEAMUS, WORKED
FOR PRESIDENT OBAMA.
HE TOOK THE SAME POSITION.
HE WOULDN'T ALLOW HIM TO COME TO